I want to start by doing an experiment
I'm going to play three videos of a
rainy day but I've replaced the audio of
one of the videos and instead of the
sound of rain I've added the sound of
bacon frying so I want you to think
carefully which one the clip with the
bacon is
all right so actually I lied they're all
bacon
[Applause]
my point here isn't really to make you
hungry every time you see a rainy scene
but it's to show that our brains are
conditioned to embrace the lies we're
not looking for accuracy so on the
subject of deception
I wanted to quote one of my favorite
authors in the decay of the art of lying
Oscar Wilde establishes the idea that
all bad art comes from copying nature
and being realistic and all great art
comes from lying and deceiving and
telling beautiful untrue things so when
you're watching a movie and the phone
rings it's not actually ringing it's
been added later in post-production in a
studio all of the sounds you hear are
fake everything apart from the dialogue
is fake when you watch a movie and you
see a bird flapping its wings they
haven't really recorded the bird it
sounds a lot more realistic if you
record a sheet or shaking kitchen gloves
the burning of a cigarette up close it
actually sounds a lot more authentic if
you take a small saran wrap ball and
release it punches oops we play that
again that's often done by sticking a
knife in vegetables usually cabbage the
next one
it's breaking bones well no one was
really harmed it's actually breaking
celery or frozen lettuce
yeah making the right sounds is not
always as easy as a trip to the
supermarket and going to the vegetable
section but it's often a lot more
complicated than that
so let's reverse engineer together the
creation of a sound effect one of my
favorite stories comes from Frank
Serafini
he's a contributor to our library and a
great sound designer for Tron and Star
Trek and others he was part of the of
the paramount team that won the Oscar
for best sound for The Hunt for Red
October
so in this Cold War classic in the 90s
they were asked to produce the sound of
the propeller of the submarine so they
had a small problem they couldn't really
find a submarine in West Hollywood so
basically what they did is they went to
a friend's swimming pool and Frank
performed a cannonball or Boba they
place an underwater mic and an overhead
mic outside the swimming pool so here's
what the the underwater mic sounds like
adding the overhead mic it sound a bit
like this so now they took the sound and
pitched it one octave down sort of like
slowing down a record
and then they removed a lot of the high
frequencies and pitched it down another
octave and then they added a little bit
of the splash from the overhead
microphone and by looping in repeating
that sound they got this so you know
creativity and technology put together
in order to create the illusion that
we're inside the submarine but once
you've created your sounds and you sync
up them to the image you want those
sounds to live in the world of the story
and one of the best ways to do that is
to add reverb so this is the first audio
tool I want to talk about reverberation
or reverb is the persistence of the
sound after the original sound has ended
so it's sort of like the other
reflections from the materials the
objects and the walls around the sounds
take for example the sound of a gunshot
which the original sound is less than
half a second long by adding reverb we
can make it sound like it was recorded
inside a bathroom or like it was
recorded inside a chapel or a church
or in a canyon so reverb gives us a lot
of information about the space between
the listener in the original sound
source if the sound is the taste
then reverb is sort of like the smell of
the sound but reverb can do a lot more
listening to a sound with a lot less
reverberation than the on screen action
is going to immediately signify to us
that we're listening to a commentator to
an objective narrator that's not
participating in the on-screen action
also emotionally intimate moments in
cinema are often heard with zero reverb
because that's how it would sound if
someone was speaking inside our ear well
the completely other side adding a lot
of reverb to a voice is going to make us
think that we're listening to a
flashback or perhaps that we're inside
the head of a character or that we're
listening to the voice of God or even
more powerful in film Morgan Freeman you
know so but what are some other tools or
hacks that sound designers use well
here's a really big one it's silence a
few moments of silence is going to make
us pay attention and in the western
world we're not really used to verbal
silences they're considered awkward or
rude so silence proceeding verbal
communication is can create a lot of
tension but imagine a really big sort of
Hollywood movie where it's full of
explosions and an automatic automatic
guns loud stops being loud anymore after
a while so in a yin-yang way silence
needs loudness and loudness need silence
for either of them to have any effect
but what the silence mean well
depends how it's used in each film
silence can place it inside the head of
a character or provoke thought we often
relate silences with contemplation
meditation being deep in thought but
apart from having one meaning silence
becomes a blank canvas upon which the
viewer is invited to paint their own
thoughts but I wanted to make it clear
there is no such thing as silence and I
know this sounds like the most
pretentious TED talk statement ever but
even if you were to enter a room with
zero reverberation in 0 external sounds
you would still be able to hear the
pumping of your own blood and in cinema
traditionally there was never a silent
moment because of the sound of the
projector and even in today's Dolby
world there's not really any moment of
silence if you listen around you this
will be some sort of noise now since
there's no such thing as silence what do
filmmakers and sound designers use well
as a synonym they often use ambiences
ambiences are the unique background
sounds that are specific to each
location each location has a unique
sound and each room has a unique sound
which is called room tone so here's a
recording of a market in Morocco
and here's a recording of Times Square
in New York
[Music]
room tone is the addition of all the
noises inside the room the ventilation
the heating the fridge so here's a
recording of my apartment in Brooklyn
ambiences work in the most primal way
they can speak directly to our brain
subconsciously so birds chirping outside
your window may indicate normality
perhaps because as a species we've been
used to that sound every morning for
millions of years on the other hand
industrial sounds have been introduced
to us a little more recently even though
I really like them personally have been
used by one of my heroes David Lynch and
his sound designer Alan's split
industrial sounds often carry negative
connotations
now sound effects can tap into our
emotional memory occasionally they can
be so significant that they become a
character in a movie the sound of
thunder may indicate divine intervention
or anger
church bells can remind us of the
passing of time or perhaps our own
mortality and breaking of glass can
indicate the end of a relationship or a
friendship now scientists believe that
dissonant sounds for example brass or
wind instruments played very loud may
remind us of animal howls in nature and
therefore create a sense of irritation
or fear
[Music]
[Applause]
so now we've spoken about on-screen
sounds but occasionally the source of a
sound cannot be seen that's what we call
off-screen sounds or aquas Matic
acousmatic sounds well the term echoes
Matic comes from pythagoras in ancient
greece who used to teach behind a veil
or curtain for years not revealing
himself to his disciples I think the
mathematician and philosopher thought
that in that way his students might
focus more on the voice and his words
and its meaning rather than of the
visual of him speaking so sort of like
The Wizard of Oz or or 1984's big
brother separating the voice from its
source
separating cause and effect sort of
creates a sense of ubiquity or Panopto
system and therefore authority there's a
strong tradition of a cosmetic sound
nuns in monasteries in Rome and Venice
used to sing in rooms up in galleries
close to the ceiling creating the
illusion that we're listening to angels
up in the sky Richard Wagner famously
created the hidden Orchestra that was
placed in a pit between the stage and
the audience and one of my heroes a fix
twin famously hid in dark corners of
clubs I think what all these masters
knew is that by hiding the source you
create a sense of mystery this has been
seen in cinema over and over with
Hitchcock and Ridley Scott an alien
hearing a sound without knowing its
source is going to create some sort of
tension also it can minimize certain
visual restrictions the directors have
and can show something that wasn't there
during filming and if all this sounds a
little theoretical I wanted to play a
little video
[Music]
[Applause]
get the written a bit bit bit written
what I'm sort of trying to demonstrate
with these tools is that sound is a
language it can trick us by transporting
us geographically it can change the mood
it can set the pace can make us laugh or
it can make it scared and on a personal
level I fell in love with that language
a few years ago and somehow managed to
make it into some sort of profession and
I think with our work through the sound
library we're trying to kind of expand
the vocabulary of that language and in
that way we want to offer the right
tools to sound designers filmmakers
video game and app designers to keep
telling even better stories and creating
even more beautiful lies so thanks for
listening
[Applause]
you